hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
concerns of Rene Descartes meditations
is being able to distinguish the true
from the false and these are terms that
we use quite easily without sometimes
understanding precisely what we mean
when we say that something is false or
that something is true and in meditation
3 this is going to play an important
role and get some preliminary
clarification on the part of Descartes
he's going to make some important
distinctions about the ways in which
something can be said to be false now
this is incredibly important because the
entire Cartesian method of hyperbolic or
methodological or metaphysical doubt
however you want to describe it depended
on treating things that are doubtful as
if they are indeed false so in what
sense are those things false about
midway through the third meditation
Descartes talks about a distinction
between being false in terms of true and
formal falsity and material falsity now
he's using
rather scholastic terminology there but
I think you can see what he means
quite quite easily when we look at what
he says so he says as I remarked earlier
it's only in judgments that one can find
true and formal falsity and now that's
kind of an interesting way to talk about
it true falsity falsity in the truest
sense falsity you could say in its
essential pattern or or nature and so
he's saying this relies on us making
judgments and what is a judgment a
judgment is an affirmation or denial of
something being the case it has you
could say a propositional content it
affirms or denies something of something
and it's an act that we engage in with
their mind whether we do so merely in
thought or do so linguistically it is a
complex thing so it is connecting up
several different ideas and making some
sort of affirmation or denial that is
where genuine falsity or formal falsity
or true falsity resides for Descartes
now he talks then about a material
falsity as well and he says that we can
still nevertheless find in ideas a
certain material falsity that is when
they represent what is not or what is
nothing as if it was something and here
he's kind of speaking in shorthand he
talks about something that's nothing
Karianna but we could also think of that
this as talking about something that is
other that is different right so when
ideas represent things for example if I
have an idea
a unicorn and then I tack on as some
people have done and
I remember this is from the 70s and 80s
they would add some Pegasus wings to it
and somebody had come along and said
that's not a real unicorn
well a unicorn isn't real anyway there's
a material falsity to unicorn a horse
with a horn on it just as much as there
is if you add some wings to it right and
may as well you know color them
different colors and make them rainbow
we can imagine whatever we want when it
comes to unicorns right but the idea
doesn't represent the reality and in
that sense you can say that it has a
certain material falsity there's a
disconnect in what the idea is
representing and whether there's any
such thing like that in existence now a
little bit earlier you notice the cart
here referred back to a distinction that
he was making this is earlier in the
third meditation he says that if we
think about the thoughts that we have
right and where we can find truth and
falsity he says that among my thoughts
some are like images of things and those
are the ones that we should properly
call ideas because they represent things
like like a human being or a chimera or
the sky or an angel or even God and then
he says of the others beyond this they
have different forms for example when I
will or wish when I fear when I affirm
and when I deny I conceive he says
something like the subject of the action
of my mind but I add also something by
that action to the idea that I have of
that thing and of this genre of thoughts
he says some of these are called
Volition's willings votantes right or
affections meaning emotions desires all
the
sorts of effective states and others are
called judgments so we have now three
different types of thoughts we have
ideas properly speaking representing
things we have affections and Volition's
and then we have the judgments that we
just talked about so he tells us where
are we gonna find falsity in ideas now
we just talked about them not
representing things accurately as they
are and in that we can talk about a
certain material falsity considered
solely as ideas considered in themselves
as images that are presented to us there
is no falsity to them we are in fact
truly experiencing them whether it be
through what we take to be sense
perception or imagination or even if you
know we're doing something intellectual
with the understanding it that would be
the case as well so he says so for what
concerns ideas if we consider them in
solely in themselves and we don't
connect them to some other thing they
can't properly speaking be false
there is no falsity in them except in
this material sense of not corresponding
to something else consider just as the
ideas or images that we're being
presented with they're completely true
and it's also true to say I have these
ideas I am experiencing these ideas I am
imagining this what about our affections
and Volition's can we speak of them
being true or false Descartes says yes
we can and and there's a long tradition
going back quite a ways of saying maybe
when it comes to emotions and choices or
decisions we can find some criteria by
which to call them true or false in some
practical sense right Descartes says we
don't have to fear either that we would
encounter falsity in a fact
or Volition's why not why can't my
Volition's be false in the sense of
being wrong willing the wrong thing
right he says well because even though I
can desire bad things or even what will
never come to pass
nevertheless it is for that no less true
that I do in fact desire them so if
we're considering Volition's we're
considering desires we're considering
emotional reactions as the ideas that we
actually have within ourselves
there's nothing false about them it's
only insofar as we relate them somehow
to something else and this is why
judgment is so absolutely central when
it comes to falsity for Descartes what
goes on in a judgment as I remarked
earlier judgments are competent they
involve affirming and denying which
remember were among the modes of thought
that Descartes said when what am i a
thinking substance I am a being that
thinks I am a being that imagines I'm a
being that wills I'm also a being that
affirms and denies and affirming and
denying is engaging in judgment so I
says so all that remains are judgments
in which I must take guard cautiously
not to fool myself because the principle
error and the most common one that I'm
going to encounter consists in that I
judge that the ideas that I have in
myself are resembling or in conformity
you could say corresponding to the
things that are outside of myself that
is the common judgment that I'm making
all of the time and that is a judgment
that's not simply registering something
that is the mind saying I have this idea
this idea corresponds to something out
there
have an idea of a book it's this book
alright this object that I'm perceiving
you're perceiving now as well as an idea
so he says certainly if I consider just
the ideas like certain modes or fashions
of my thought without wanting or willing
choosing to connect them to something
else that's exterior then I have no
occasion to go astray
I'm not affirming that they actually do
correspond to things or denying that so
this is an important point and what's
going on metaphysically when there's
falsity in our our judgment in our grasp
on things or even in the material
falsity about the idea is not actually
connecting up with the things that that
are so you talks about ideas that
represent things that are not and here
we we might think about this in several
different ways the cart is running
through this rather summarily but we
should distinguish here several
different ways in which we might have
ideas of things that are are not right
one would be that we have an idea of
something that simply is not the case at
all doesn't exist period so again the
Unicorn
or the square circle you know
absurdities things along those lines
then we might also have ideas about
things that we represent to ourselves in
ways that don't actually depict the
thing that that's out there so for
example when we are thinking about human
beings who we encounter there is a
possibility that cart considers that
maybe they're not genuinely human beings
but machines that clothing is is placed
upon and they're there to trick us or
something like that in that case we
would have something we would have an
idea and the idea would be in some way
connected to a reality or an external
thing but the external thing and the
idea don't actually map on
to each other right so we don't have a
total lack of existence we have a
non-existing in this way and then he
uses the example of heat and coldness
and he says these are we take these for
granted but these are actually rather
unclear and obscure ideas and maybe they
don't reflect anything genuinely out
there I mean we we nowadays think that
it has to do with you know the vibration
of of atoms right and how fast they're
going and and we think about heat in
that way we think about radiant energy
but with the cart with what he's working
with he's saying listen the ideas that
we actually have of heat and cold you
know we we can have these ideas but do
they actually map onto anything perhaps
not because they're confused in
themselves so where do we get this
falsity or confusion from here's where
Descartes says something really quite
interesting metaphysically and it would
be very easy for a reader to pass over
this this is something that is central
to the Cartesian metaphysics he says
that they proceed or arise from
nothingness nay onth is the word that
he's using there and what does that
really mean he says that they are in me
this is the formulation because of a
lack a monk or an imperfection within me
so the nothingness is not somewhere out
there right the the nothingness is
actually within myself there's some some
sort of privation or something that's
that that ought to be there that isn't
there or just doesn't happen to be there
and that's why we get things wrong when
we get them wrong now that that
nothingness or or privation generally is
going to take the form of the judgments
that we're making and the last thing
I'll say about this is Descartes thinks
that we're making judgments much more
often than we actually realize that
we're doing and part of the Cartesian
meditations is to help us attend to
those judgments that we are in fact
making so we can determine where falsity
actually resides the answer to that is
in its proper sense in our judgments not
in the ideas themselves not in the
thoughts that we call affections or
Volition's but in that that species of
thought that we call judgment that
consists in affirming and denying
you